hey what is up guys mkbhd here and every
few months we get another awesome new
flagship phone with you know high-end
specs great hardware baller set of
features uh and we love it we love it
when these new high-end phones come out
that's always great but then sometimes a
couple of weeks later we'll see this
prime version of the phone sometimes
it's a rumor sometimes it actually comes
out with a slightly improved feature set
slightly better specs and you gotta
wonder what is that what does that mean
is that should we pay attention to these
are we getting screwed over
this is those prime phones explained all
right so check this out this is the
samsung galaxy s5 great specs high-end
android phone from samsung that we all
know basically all their best parts and
this is the samsung galaxy s5 prime or
the lte-a version of a galaxy s5 so from
the outside you can barely really tell
any difference they're the same
dimensions same materials and all the
same parts
so no metal build or anything like that
but the prime has an ltea logo on the
back and it also has a gold trim
everywhere where the regular galaxy s5
had a silver trim again not a different
material or anything just a different
colored trim
so the real difference really between
these two phones is all with the specs
instead of a regular galaxy s5 5.1 inch
1080p display this version has a 5.1
inch
2560x1440 display a big bright beautiful
2.5 k oled display even sharper than the
lg g3 so in a really impressive panel
and inside it goes from a snapdragon 801
to a snapdragon 805 and goes from 2 gigs
of ram to 3 gigs of ram it also contains
a new lte modem that supports lte
advanced or what we call category 6 lte
and this is actually the main purpose of
the existence of this device at all it's
on the back it's on the box in the us
and most lte markets we have category 4
lte most carriers max out with this at
about 75 megabits per second tops but
the limit of the technology is 150
megabits per second that's pretty fast
but this ltea galaxy s5 moves up to the
category 6 lte or cat6 and it's made
specifically for one market in south
korea where sk telecom is rolling out
their advanced lte network their speeds
are now 225 megabits per second and the
technology maxes out at 300 megabits per
second so it's a new phone specifically
for this south korea market with this
south korean carrier in an area where
ltea is just now rolling out hardly a
new phone at all but yes still different
now could samsung have released this
galaxy s5 everywhere with ltea and a 2.5
k display and snapdragon 805
yes
but that would have pissed off a lot of
current galaxy s5 owners and lta really
isn't available much of anywhere yet but
really samsung always releases multiple
versions of their galaxy phone with
certain variances over the course of the
year they do this every time so think of
this as another one of them you know we
have the galaxy s5 active the galaxy s5
zoom the galaxy s5 mini and now the
galaxy s5 lte a it's a side step variant
for a specific market here's another
example this is the lg g3 that we all
know it already has a 2.5 k display it
already has a baller display pretty much
everywhere and high end specs here in
gold is the lg g3 prime of course not
the official name it's really the lg g3
cat6 version sound familiar so now the
only difference here is again just on
the inside so same screen same build
basically same phone in every other way
but with a snapdragon 805 and three gigs
of ram and category six lte support oh
and for some reason a lot of bloatware
koreans i guess don't mind bloatware but
so you can think of these phones as
sidesteps to their flagship brothers you
know they're not sold in the united
states you won't find them in a carrier
store or anything but they're actually
pretty hard to get you actually have to
go to a specialty site that carries
stuff like this these prime phones came
from 28mobile.com
in fact i'll leave a link for each of
them below the like button if you want
to check them out but really if you're
going to import these you're not going
to be able to take advantage of ltea so
i guess if you're desperate for a 2.5 k
display on your galaxy s5 or you
absolutely must have the beefier
snapdragon 805 chip or an extra gig of
ram then sure i guess these prime phones
are for you also fun fact there were
some rumors of an htc one m8 prime and
the plans were actually leaked not with
only new specs but with a new design and
a new camera but then those plans
quickly died that would have been the
first prime phone to actually change
almost everything and basically make it
a new phone altogether but since that
never happened there you have it the
prime phones are side steps so that's
been it thank you guys for watching if
you enjoyed it feel free to hit that
thumbs up button below or share it with
other people who you think might be
curious about these prime phones thank
you for watching and i'll talk to you
guys in the next video
peace